and I did wonder six years ago would
have been that we heard that London and
one in a bid for the Olympics and passed
mail is sort of overjoyed at the thought
of olympic games in our own country and
you know me having a chance in my
lifetime to compete as a home games that
possibly though but surely it's not
going to be half as good as the Sydney
Olympics or the Beijing Olympics where
you're traveling you know to the other
side of the world but I can honestly say
now having done the Olympics donor
london olympic games that it was the
best one that I've been to and you know
as I'm sure we were all closed up when
we invested in pick spirits and the
equestrian sports we were in Greenwich
Park and it was great as a as a rider to
be in Greenwich and so near the sort of
main parts of the Olympic Games I'm so
often equestrianism is sort of a way
away from the main Olympics you know for
example in Beijing we were in Hong Kong
which was three hours of right away and
although they make it as Olympic II as
possible it's not quite the same as
being right there in the thick of it and
also for me what makes it so thrilling
being in the thick of s is living in
that Olympic Village and I think as a
young person with you know aspirations
to try and get to an Olympic Games
that's you know being in the Olympic
Village as one of the things that you
know really sort of you know appeal to
me and you know is fascinated to
you know me as to us it would be like
and it is absolutely fantastic because
everybody in lat Olympic Village is an
athlete no nobody else is allowed in
except the athletes and the coaches and
so when you sort of walk through the
village you know everybody there is yet
the top of the school top their game and
then has worked so hard to get there and
be there and be all in a way it sort of
brings you all together all the nations
all the sports people you're there
together as one in the village and it's
the most fantastic especially experience
being in there but yes our sport was you
know miss Durham you mentioned it was
right at the beginning of the Olympic
period and see a great britain haven't
really delivered sort of early on with
the medals so you know there was funny
obviously there's lots of pressure
anyway but especially you know people
are sort of hoping that we might do well
and it was just fantastic to job that
last show German yes to know that I've
done it human a lot of relief prezzo
lots of it appears that ever thrill of
don't enough done my basin and we won
that silver medal and I think because we
were one of the early medalists it we
has a lot of media coverage and having
Zara Phillips princess and stores are in
our team that also made us you know
maybe that brilliantly are very
interested in us so we hads you know
it's very very so exciting you know
after that and you know there's a few
days following on from from our middle
win but as it turned out you know great
britain with fantastic went and won all
those gold medals later on so just as
well we went in the second week we might
might also be noted so much
and there's any way that say yes Tara
mentioned this was my sixth Olympics I
can't believe I've been at it for so
long and gonna be unfortunate enough to
know when bronze in Beijing and silver
in Athens I was hoping to complete the
set in London but you know on the silver
again which was wonderful to meddle in
London it's just made me think you know
I've just got to keep going now for
another four years try